in today's date on your side Google
flights experimenting with offering a
price match guarantee with money back
our travel expert weighs and on the pros
and the caveats with choosing to book
this way
you've been scouring the websites and
believe you've found the best flight
deal you buy your ticket and wonder what
if the fare drops afterward Google
flights thinks it has the solution in
early April it began offering a price
match guarantee and they're monitoring
it for you so you're not having to set a
bunch of alerts which is really great
Katie nastro of going says the pilot
program allows people to save money
here's how it works you buy your flights
through the book on Google Checkout
platform and you set up Google pay
that's the portal you would get the
refund through when you book that flight
if there is an opportunity where it does
drop you don't have to do anything you
are just getting that cash back after
you take that flight so it's really
doing all the legwork behind the scenes
for you because without Google flights
price match guarantee nastro says if you
get an alert about a cheaper flight you
still have to get in touch with the
airline to cancel your original flight
and then rebook the cheaper one once you
get the credit nastro says the ease of
the Google flight price match guarantee
is attracting more people to its website
but keep in mind this is a pilot program
not every flight has the price match
guarantee right now Alaska Hawaiian
Airlines and spirit are the airlines
offering the feature through the book on
Google Checkout platform also it can
only be used for flights that are
domestic or originate in the United
States and here is one more restriction
because you can't do this on multi-city
itineraries you know so 2-1 ways in
different cities you know outside of the
US it must have that badge that
signifies that it's offered and not all
airlines are participating
refunds are capped at 500 per year
Google tried this out briefly in 2019
but the pandemic of course brought that
to a halt then Capital One also offers
it through its revamped Capital One
travel portal it's also important to
note Southwest Airlines not included